what's your take been on you know it's
with you that than on the night of
course and that was very sad evening
indeed as we've moved on now we're
beginning to look ahead as well as
recognize the enormous contributions
this late queen made as we look ahead to
king charles iii are you as encouraged
as i am i think arthur is by the start
he's made completely appears it's as
though he's grown a foot taller in in
strength in confidence and i think he's
drawing strength and reassurance from
his subjects
and actually we his subjects are also
drawing comfort and reassurance from
from from his strength and for how he's
conducting himself for the way that this
has just seamlessly
transitioning
from
from the late queen
from all of her extraordinary
achievements but actually i really do
think this is this is going to give the
whole nation real confidence i draw huge
strength from it much more than i think
any of us could possibly have expected
ava do you see yourself as a subject do
people your age even like the idea of
being anyone's subject and is that an
issue for the future of the monarchy i
think it's a difficult question at the
moment in this 10-day period of mourning
because i mean look it's a subject
steeped in history which i think is
fascinating i think that a lot of people
can have massive appreciation for but
you know
i i don't think that we also need to
feel
as subjects i don't i think it's
perfectly okay to be quite sad about the
queen and to appreciate her legacy but
also say you know there's quite a few
things around the monarchy that i don't
really appreciate and like what in your
case well today for example i didn't
really appreciate police officers using
the 2022 uh police bill
to drag protesters off the streets and
say that we weren't allowed to object to
the monarchy i mean i didn't appreciate
i mean i didn't like what they were
saying but i absolutely defend their
right to protest
and there are a body of people in this
country who will agree with some of
these prejudices take a look at some of
the protests today
it's interesting that particular
incident because i think it's completely
disrespectful to have done that anywhere
near the queen's
heart obviously however i also thought
it was a big risk
by the royal family to let prince andrew
after all that's gone on with him in the
last year
walk through the streets in that way
now they would say and i understand this
he was a beloved son of the queen and
she would famously described him to
people sometimes apparently her favorite
son i'm not sure that's actually true
but that was what was reported
but
it notwithstanding that it's only a few
months ago that he paid off a woman who
accused him of sexually abusing her
millions and millions of dollars having
said he'd go to court and clear his name
is it irrational for some people
to think this is completely
inappropriate
well i mean he he didn't pay let's be
clear about that we paid we the taxpayer
paid that and you know
i would say that it was disrespectful to
her and her legacy actually to the
people who loved the queen for him to
walk behind the carriage i thought that
was really disrespectful actually you
know i think it's really i'm sorry he is
a grieving son for his mother i think i
think it's mean-spirited i think it's
heartless frankly you know we a nation
are grieving but they are a family yep a
family in greece i think
walk through the entire nation to pay
their respects so they don't need to be
there for the entire funeral this is
this is the royal moment this is you
know and yes but that i think is a sign
of the openness and the transparency
with which child is going to govern open
and transparent we could talk about the
fact that a lot of people have had to
cancel the funerals for their own
mothers because of the queen and respect
and homage to the queen and there are a
lot of people at the moment who are
actually having to rent coffins because
they can't afford to buy them so if
we're going to talk about respect we
should talk about it across the border
we should have a little bit of nuance
well i think that actually it's about
people's love and appreciation and
devotion to our monarch the queen to the
queen
what is your view of this andrew
situation
i i mean i didn't like for example that
he wore his military uniform for the
vigil apparently it's the only part of
the entire week where he'll wear a
military uniform but if you're in one of
the regiments that he did represent i
know there's a lot of ill feeling
towards him from members of those
regiments that he still seems like he's
representing them after what he did now
what do you think well i was there in
portsmouth when he came back after the
falklands war and we were cheering him
and we were only we laid his life on the
line for this country
i've worked with him for years and i
really like him and he's made a big
mistake in his life which was giving
that interview to emily maitland i don't
care what you say i mean if he'd have
said to her i did do that i was lonely
there was a mistake and i apologize it
would have none of this trouble but the
fact that he lied was the mistake now
well then well hang on arthur that may
not be the only one
i just want to finish
my point that may not be the only
mistake he made i must be clear he paid
a woman to avoid having his supposed day
in court he paid him millions of dollars
it may be that he was guilty of what she
accused him of otherwise why are you
paying someone millions of dollars we
don't know that and we're never going to
find out now but it may not have been
his only mistake
to do that interview well
okay fine all right but it was
highlighted he made a mistake in his
life we've all made mistakes in our life
we'd like to be highlighted every one of
us you me
never ever had to pay 12. we haven't no
we wouldn't have to do that because
you're not a prince of the realm that's
why
and the fact is that you know i think he
should be walking behind his mother's
coffin i think he should if he of course
i do i mean he's it's god he's grieving
he's broken should people who are angry
about it be treated in the way that
protests i don't think people should be
allowed to sort of disrupt that that
that comment or the queen sorry i
thought you were going to go on the
other side of it no
no no no i i i you know i agree with
people you have your right to say it but
there are times when you you don't do it
well i think it's wrong i think it's
inappropriate to do it for the way they
did it but i don't think they should
start being called away manhandled or
arrested and some of them have
i mean i'll be really living in a
country where people get arrested for
exercising their right to free speech to
protest monarchy
it's a fine balance judgment but the
reality is you know this is a democracy
and in a sense i think they've got the
right to grieve as a family it's not
prince andrew's choice you know he's
he's got a right to grieve with his
argue that
and then when someone says something you
don't particularly like arrest them